hello I'm Elizabeth Bradley the faculty
director at the global health Leadership
Institute at Yale University and I'm
joined today by David Berg an
organizational psychologist who's a
clinical professor in the Department of
Psychiatry so nice to have you here nice
to be here
well I wanted to begin with a big
question and I think it'll take us some
time to tease apart but the question I
want to ask is how do you build
organizational effectiveness and what I
mean by organizational is that it could
be a hospital it could be the emergency
room it could be a pharmaceutical
company and insurance coming but it is a
defined organization that is trying to
execute some work how do we build that
organization to maximize its
effectiveness well it's a big question
and I will probably answer it
differently than other people because
there's an organizational psychologist
my interest is not so much in using some
outcome as a way of defining
effectiveness like you deliver all your
packages on time which could be a
measure of effectiveness certainly a
measure of success what I'm interested
in is what were the processes that
allowed you and enabled you to deliver
all your packages on time or to have a
low infection rate or any of the number
of outcome measures that are measures of
success but not necessarily help you
understand how you get there so when I
think about organizational effectiveness
from that point of view which is what
are the processes that get you there I
get to a very distilled definition and
and then I related to everything else
that goes on so the distill definition
is organizational effectiveness varies
that is it'll be go up when the
following thing goes up which is people
who are involved in a task meaningfully
as opposed to
being informed about a task people
involved in a task who feel able to say
what they think and feel positive and
negative about the task in front of them
that's my one sentence definition of
organizational effectiveness and the
reason I say that is because
organizations are defined by
coordinating people's efforts otherwise
we're just a craft person a doc alone a
doc in a healthcare system is connected
to other people and the capacity of that
system to be effective is I think
related to the capacity tax system to
access information about what's going on
and then to make decisions about how to
improve or change those things but I'm a
little confused because if you really
say it's about having everybody involved
with the task able to say what they
think and feel about the task or about
each other at all times and couldn't
that really get a team into pretty
difficult territory if people really say
what they think and feel at all times so
that it it's crucial when I say about
the task I'm actually not saying about
each other
unless there's a reaction to each other
that that that relates to the task so
for example it's the in the classic
example about the challenge of doing
this is the effect of for example
hierarchy on the capacity of an
organization to do this so that the
expression that it's hard to deliver bad
news up the hierarchy from my point of
view is a statement about the
effectiveness of the organization and if
you ask people in senior roles they'll
say one of my biggest challenges is
getting people to tell me what they
actually think especially when what they
think is critical of what they imagine
to be my goal or my objective and that
puts the in this case the senior person
at risk for making a bad decision or for
coming up with a poor strategy because
people who have other sources of
information are unable unwilling feel
that they can't say what they're
thinking and feeling especially as it
relates to up the hierarchy that's
usually Nega
thought or feeling so but it's about the
task it's not John I really don't like
you it's John I think you're you're
you're not you don't have all the
information about X and I wouldn't have
done Y if I had all the information let
me tell you what the information is that
I have so let's take this from you
introduce the idea of hierarchy so let's
take this from being the person at the
top of the hierarchy and then being
people who are really following that so
first being at the top of the hierarchy
what can you really do I mean what can
you do if people sometimes just don't
have the courage to tell you what's
going on and you all of a sudden realize
that patients have been waiting for
hours in the emergency room no one told
you you have no idea so I don't know if
I ever would have thought of that as an
organizational problem don't most people
think of that as somebody on the team
just has a problem they're not able to
tell you the truth yep that that is the
way most people think about it
I don't think about if you frame it as
courage you're framing it as an
individual characteristic and now you're
trying to select people who are
courageous but most of our evidence
right this umberto experiment so Philip
Zimbardo they just made a recent movie
about this did an experiment at Stanford
where he randomly assigned students to
roles of guards and inmates and what
essentially was disturbing about it and
not the first thing but because you
don't usually do a role play like this
that goes on for the schedule to go on
for a week and goes on for three days
and has to be stopped
because of how powerfully people take on
the roles what we learned from this is
that this is going to be a slight
overstatement but you let me control the
conditions I can probably get anybody to
do anything
which means courage is probably a
reflection of the social structure
that's been created in the organization
rather than a characteristic of the
person if someone is behaving
courageously or more broadly if you want
most of the people in your organization
to behave courageously
you're probably going to have to do
something with the setting in which they
find themselves rather than in selecting
quote-unquote courageous
that's good and bad news the good news
is you don't have to rely on the and the
tails of the distribution of courage to
have people say what they're thinking
and feeling the bad news is your next
question is going to be so what do you
do in organizations to make it more
likely that people behave quote/unquote
courageously I actually before we get
there I want to think about what goes
wrong in these kinds of situations so
you hold this you're the brand new
director of a department and you hear
people griping about the department they
don't think it's very good they don't
but you hear it sideways you hear it
from your confidence or a few people so
you decide let's have a staff meeting
let's sit down and let's talk it out
okay what do you think happens I mean
that can turn into complete disaster
short term well I actually think the
bigger risk is not the disaster you may
be referring to which is people actually
gripe session right I don't think a
gripe session is the worst case scenario
by a long shot because it depends on
what one does with the gripes the worst
problem is if people have gripes and
don't say them because then you walk out
thinking everything's fine only the
processes that got you to call the
meeting continue in New York in your
example what I would diagnose is the
problem is the person who called the
meeting doesn't understand the threat of
hierarchy to organizational
effectiveness we understand the
importance of hierarchy and
organizational effectiveness it's the
it's the coordination and authority who
gets to make decisions that are but we
think that if we sit in a room and other
people who report to us are in the room
and we say please tell me what you
honestly think we're going to get what
they honestly think when in fact they
may be quite structurally vulnerable in
terms of evaluation pay future careers
so if I want people who work for me to
be able to say what they think and feel
about the task at hand I pray and I'm in
a hierarchal relationship with them I
probably can't go in and say so tell me
what you think and feel I have to think
about something else as an example if I
thought that there was widespread
grousing about what's going
in the organization either about morale
or about a decision that we've made one
thing I could do that takes into account
that hierarchy is a threat to
effectiveness in the regard or the way
I've defined it is I could walk into a
meeting and I could say I'd like to
really know what you think of the
decision we just made I'm gonna step out
for 15 minutes
I'd like you to cover the board with the
pros and cons no names just the pros and
cons on this task so that we have them
accessible to us especially me because
I'm a little worried that people aren't
delivering to me the negative thoughts
and feelings given that I'm the boss so
I'm gonna walk out and I'll come back in
15 minutes I want to see what you're
thinking now that's not perfect because
people have to trust the other people in
the room not to squeal to the boss et
cetera but it at least acknowledges that
hierarchy presents some challenges to
organizational effectiveness as opposed
to thinking there's no hierarchy doesn't
have that I can just go and ask you what
you think and you'll tell me mm-hmm so I
think it takes thinking about the
various challenges of which hierarchy is
one and there are others so it's a
really hard task if you're in a
situation where you really just are
stretched you don't have a lot of time
but this kind of thing erupts what's
your advice I mean you hold to the
practice or do you say just a minute
we're gonna work on this but it's gonna
be a long while you know how do you do
it so first thing I would say is in
order to make this a kind of fair
discussion intellectually there's a long
tail to not having such conversations
meaning that's what most people complain
about they complain about the stuff that
nobody's telling him the grousing that
goes on underground so that no light can
be shown on it nothing can't be
addressed so yes there's potentially a
long tail to having such conversations
there's a long tail than not having okay
now in terms of the kinds of scenario
you you proposed there are two examples
I would use one from the military and
one from medicine which we generally
think of as situations often not always
but in emergent situations where things
have to be done quickly and there's some
there's some cost to delay there's some
evidence that even in those situations
you
try to slow down and and and solicit
from people who were in different parts
of the problem whether it's different
forces that parts of the room or
different parts of the battlefield or
different specialties you try to slow it
down in order to solicit their opinions
because you're in worse shape if you
don't and then the question of will they
tell you and under what conditions will
they tell you which is the real tricky
part here but both of these
organizations have also developed
something that says after you're in the
emergent situation you need to try to
find time to sit down and say what you
thought about what happened in the
military it's called an after-action
review and of course in medicine it's
called and mortality morbidity comes
incident report incident reporting
although in now the struggle is you can
have the meeting and then the question
is what happens at the meeting there's
so many reports of M&M conferences
morbidity and mortality
where nobody's saying what they're
thinking and feeling in which case
taking it offline out of the emergent
situation to try to understand it falls
prey to the same struggles we were just
talking about what's keeping people from
saying what they think and feel positive
and negative and without that
information and after-action review a
mortality conference is not terribly
useful